all right joining us now with more is
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
who has just formally requested to meet
with the president
and the biden administration over this
worsening crisis at the border
okay you've heard from tom holman we've
been reporting and showing video all
week
uh congressman and i got to tell you
something it's from what we're seeing
and hearing and showing it's the worst
it's ever been
you're exactly correct and this byte
administration cannot ignore what they
ignited
a crisis at this border weak policies
from a weak administration
i've requested as the republican leader
to sit down with the president
to talk about this crisis they have to
acknowledge of what they created it is
simply within two months
their actions creating a crisis on the
border
which only harms the health of all
americans they are moving these
individuals in they are encouraging
the dhs secretary has encouraged people
to come
he says we're not saying not to come
just don't come right now
going against the actual law of america
but moving them in in a world of covid
right now with no testing
putting them throughout this country
when our schools can't even open
up i mean you make it a great point and
you see that now they're allowing 100
capacity that means it's impossible to
have social distancing we had 108 people
now testing positive for covert then
they're now moving
and allowing again it's catch and
release
okay you get to catch them you process
them
they get a court date we know from
history they're never going to show up
on the court date okay so basically then
they'll be part of the amnesty of joe
biden
which he's now promising which is now
serving as a magnet for people around
the world to
to go through the perilous journey
dangerous journey with young kids
to make it to the u.s no thinking that
joe's given them amnesty
and citizenship yeah
it doesn't matter the records that are
being broken right now could you
only imagine the number of people are
going to be next month and the month
after
the millions of people who will be down
there instead of being checked for
asylum while you sit in another country
even though you passed
two other countries to get here joe
biden has now said come on in
open the door he stopped finishing the
wall so i've talked to many of
my members yvette harold of new mexico
she has a constituent right on the
border that they
they stopped building the wall now they
have the fear of what the cartel is
doing in others
this makes it unsafe not just for
individuals that are being trafficked in
others that you get the reports
about the children but now we've got
drugs moving across
we've got covid moving across but we've
got an administration
not only welcoming it encouraging it
where you're reporting is even saying
where they're having biden signs and
shirts
they're they're being told to come here
illegally and enter this country
all right so now one house republican
went along with this
1.9 trillion dollars
a bill that had only nine percent of
money allocated for emergency code
relief
so it was one big lie this was not about
what they said it is
all right then they're gonna spend two
trillion on the new green deal
you did your job you even got one
democrat to join you
but we lost that vote now the senate
because it's reconciliation it will pass
in the senate
but h.r one should be stopped in the
senate which would be a disaster
for all future elections are you
confident the senate can stop that
i believe i talked to leader mcconnell
just last night but
you're right the only bipartisan vote in
the house
on this nancy pelosi payoff bill the
bipartisan vote was no
and now they turn right around wanting
to change our election system
you know they named the bill h.r one the
most important bill by the majority
party the democrats
and what does it do it's not about
covent it's not about putting people
back to work or back to school or back
to health
it's about taking taxpayer money and
paying for their campaign
so if aoc got two hundred dollars
someone contributed to her
the taxpayer would have to give her
twelve hundred dollars and then what
they want to do is create a speech czar
to tell us what we can
say expand this cancel culture and then
they want to change the federal election
commission
that it wouldn't be an equal number of
republicans and democrats they want it
weighted towards the democrats this is
they want to con
continue to keep themselves in power
which even
any illegal way they possibly can that's
why
every viewer that watches this has got
to join with us go to takethehouse.com
we've got to stop hr1 because you know
what's happening in the weeks to come
they're coming after our guns next
they're going to tell us what we can say
and what we can't
i mean it's just perpetuating every fear
that we had
if this socialist democratic party was
able to gain the senate and the white
house
and they're proving it their socialist
policies and agenda
is wrong for this nation and in a short
two months
what is the price of gasoline iran is
now sending missiles into iraq
china feels free to go in and push
around our friends and neighbors based
upon who's in the administration
and we still got 10 million people out
of work and they're sending more
illegals into our country
we need the senate to hold the line on
h.r 1.
your house did its job yes you got 100
even liz cheney there you go all right
maybe not as much divisiveness as
everyone claimed
uh thank you congressman uh house
minority leader kevin mccarthy when we
come